so here's some material from a home
depot in canada um talking about
privilege this was uh posted
by libs of tick tock
always doing the work
you know this is like what
really just it tells you the state of uh
of the media that i i would say that
probably the top journalist
in the country right now is the
anonymous person who runs a libs of tick
tock account on twitter
this is actual journalism finding real
stories about things that are happening
and and telling people about it um so
here's here's something it says home
depot has gone woke and there's this
worksheet that was handed out at a home
depot in canada
and it says leading practices
unpacking privilege
privilege now a special benefit or
advantage that may be earned or unearned
and then it goes into there's two kinds
of privilege social privilege
um that's a special unearned advantage
or entitlement used to one's own benefit
or to the detriment of others these
groups can be advantaged based on social
class age disability ethnic or racial
category gender gender identity sexual
orientation and religion
and that's certainly that that
definitely exists there's no question
about it i mean there are people who
have because of their
demographic category they have social
privileges there are people who have
social privileges based on their
quote-unquote gender identity
um
in fact the kinds of people who use
phrases like gender identity and think
that that's a real thing those are the
ones with social privilege
if you're in the if you're if you can
claim membership
to the lgbt club somehow
fit your way under that ever-expanding
umbrella then you have social privilege
but that's not the kind of privilege i
talk about i assume
um and then also white privilege that's
societal privilege that benefits white
people beyond what is commonly
experienced by people of color under the
same social political and economic
circumstances and then it goes into this
so those are the two broad categories
and then there's sort of these
subcategories and it says what privilege
looks like
if you're confident that the police
exist to protect you
you have white privilege
that's what white privilege so if you
if you do not believe
that you're being hunted down by cops
who want to execute you
while you're just walking down the
street then you have privilege
i would think of that okay if that's
privilege that's just the privilege of
not being paranoid
um
if while growing up college was an
expectation of you not a dream
you have class privilege
if you can expect time off from work to
celebrate your religious holidays
you have christian privilege
if you can use public bathrooms without
stares fear or anxiety
you have cisgender privilege
so that's that's nobody by the way like
who
does anyone feel 100 comfortable in
public restrooms
it would be kind of strange if you did
like there's always a little bit of
anxiety in public restrooms um
and then also able-bodied privilege and
heterosexual privilege
and can i also say
just a note that on the christian
privilege thing
i i've always seen it as the other way
around like
if you're getting off of work and you
get off time off of school
for someone else's religious holidays
how does that mean that you have the
privilege it seems like you get the
extra privilege there it's not even your
holiday and you get to take off
so what's what's the privilege exactly
if we're if we're inviting you we
celebrate christmas and we're saying you
know what we're gonna give everybody off
you're not even christian we're gonna
give you a christmas gift and you get to
take off also
that what is that you being oppressed
you're being attacked
um
no the the privilege would be
uh we're gonna take off for christmas
but but all of you still have to work
um
able-bodied and heterosexual privilege
so this is a home depot this is what
they're doing at home depot now home
depot responded the ap reached out to
them here's the ap says home depot said
wednesday that a worksheet about
privilege that went viral is an
unauthorized document from the company's
canada division an anonymous twitter
account with the handle libs of tick
tock uh
posted it we know that
and
they said that um
home depot issued a statement saying
that while it supports diversity at the
company the worksheet was not created or
approved by its corporate diversity
equity and inclusion department
companies said this this was a resource
in our canada division and not part of
any required programming
so that's this has already been labeled
online as misinformation and debunked
and everything and it's not this was
this was something that was used at a
home depot
and that was handed out to employees
apparently at a home depot it just
didn't come down from the top
eventually it will though because they
they admit that they have
well you know we have a corporate
diversity equity and inclusion
department it's just like that's
that particular bit of brainwashing
isn't something that came from us
so we have each individual home depot
can do their own brainwashing we have
our but we have the corporate version
and that's not part of it yet
but that's all
that's all inevitable once that the
whole point of having a diversity equity
and inclusion department is precisely
for things like this
and it's kind of significant too there's
a certain significance to home depot
starting to go woke because
um as far as i know up until now they
were one of the few companies that
had basically stayed neutral
um
they were one of the few companies that
up until this point
you know at least hadn't gone out of the
way to display their wokeness
and that apparently is that that was
that was never going to last i suppose
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends